صواريخ ومدافع روسيه على مدار اشهر
استهدفه البنيه التحتيه في اوكرانيا لا
تحقق الهدف المرجوع لروسيا بشكل تام
لتمارسها هجمات من نوع اخر حرب سيبرانيه
اقتربت بالحرب التقليديه تستخدم فيها
الهجمه الالكترونيه لنفس التاثير المدمر
للصواريخ والقذائف
صراع العصر الجديد نبه حلف الناتو الى
ابواب خطيره تفتحها الحرب سيبرانيه على
دول العالم عموما واعضاء الحلف خصوصا
والتي تقدم الدعم العسكريه والانسانيه
لكيف ما كان من اكبر حلف عسكريين الا ان
يدعم تدريباته العسكريه بتدريبات سيبرانيه
تحاكلها هجمات المتوقعه التي قد تشنها
روسيا بشكل مكثف على اوكرانيا ودول الجوار
الداعمه لها بهدف وقف الخدمات الحيويه
150 خبيره امن سيبراني من 40 دوله ومنظمه
اجتمعت في تالين العاصمه الاستونيه لخوض
تدريبات التحالف في السيبيراني 22
بغرض الرد على الهجمات على شبكات الطاقه
والسفن وغيرها
اظهرت هذه العمليه توسيع الاسره
الالكترونيه التي تتصدى للهجمات
السيبرانيه خارج الاطار العسكري ونحن
نحتاج الى التدريب على كيفيه التعاون في
هذا المجال
مخاوف عززها عملاق التكنولوجيا مايكروسوفت
من خلال تقرير يتهم فيه الحكومه الروسيه
بتنسيق ضربات سيبرانيه على اوكرانيا
الشركه زعمه النا موسكو لن تؤطر تلك
الهجمات في اوكرانيا فقط بل ستضرب سلاسل
الامداد العسكريه والانسانيه لدول الجوار
معلومات استخباراتيه حول طرق الامداد
والعمليات اللوجستيه ما يسهل الهجمه
المستقبليه
نظرا لدخول موسم الشتاء وصعوبات تنفيذ
الهجمات الماديه قد لا تتمتع الفتره
القادمه بالهدوء المتوقع بل تشتعل الحرب
من خلف الشاشات لا من خلف المدفعيات